du côté du royaume uni l'épidémie a fait
plus de vingt mille 700 décès dans les
seuls hôpitaux mais la courbe commence à
s'inverser selon boris johnson le
premier ministre britannique robin
ducobu 19 et qui appelle lui les
britanniques à rester confinés il a fait
ce matin sa première apparition publique
depuis sa guérison et l'âme medjahed
sorti des soins intensifs depuis une
quinzaine de jours
boris johnson est désormais totalement
remis de son infection au kovy 19
le premier ministre britannique a donc
repris la main sur les affaires du
royaume uni et fait sa première
déclaration à la presse ce lundi que
boeing seul en lice ed rec les insultes
je veux m'adresser aux acteurs
économiques aux entrepreneurs à tout ce
dont notre économie dépend
vim
je comprends votre impatience je sais
que sans une impulsion un vrai sens il
n'y aura plus l'économie de notre pays
votre urgence c'est celle du
gouvernement nous devons reconnaître le
risque d'une seconde vague le risque de
perdre le contrôle face à ce virus et
news ce ne sera pas une nouvelle vague
de morts mais aussi un désastre
économique
dans un document mais qui plus est
boris johnson fait face à une pression
grandissante pour dévoiler son plan de
déconfinement le leader conservateur de
55 ans doit également affronter les
critiques pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
un schéma se dessine ici nous avons été
lents à entrer finement lent sur les
dépistages lent à mettre en place des
équipements de protection
l'ac milan a accepté des offres
d'équipements britannique
le premier secrétaire affirme qu'il ya
une capacité de 40 me teste par jour
cela signifie qu avant-hier sa quarante
mille tests auraient pu être effectuée
que mai mais que seuls 18 mille ont été
réalisés critiques de l'opposition mais
aussi division en coulisses au sein même
de l'équipe au pouvoir selon la presse
britannique certains poids lourds
s'inquiètent des conséquences sociales
mais aussi sanitaire d'un confinement
trop strictes sur la longueur boris
johnson va donc devoir trancher avec une
équation délicate à résoudre comment
faire redémarrer l'économie au royaume
uni sont risquées un deuxième pic de la
pandémie